do you believe that it's been proven
that co2 is the primary control knob for
climate do you believe that no I would
not agree that it's a primary
contributor to the city global warming
that we see mr. Pruit there are all
kinds of studies that contradict you
simple question what if you're wrong
[Music]
there are scientists that believe that
that's not happening there was an
overwhelming science if the earth was
flat
hurricane County slammed into New York
City last night flooding the World Trade
Center site with the evidence for over
for climate change is overwhelming
an elected official stands in denial of
climate change that is the end of an
informed democracy
without a doubt in my mind I believe
vaccinations triggered Evans autism they
need to wake up and stop hurting our
kids in 2014 a total of 644 measles
cases were reported the highest number
in 20 years even Darwin said that in
order to prove evolution you would need
literally thousands maybe millions of
fossils that were transitional we should
be able to find them but of course we
haven't been able to find them
[Music]
you
[Music]
welcome everybody I'm Kyle Gibson and
I'll explain very quickly what I'm doing
up here I'm a graduate of Yale College I
want to say what year I will cop to the
fact that I am a member of the first
ever varsity Yale women's soccer team
and we won the Irish and pin shift the
year we were formed so I'm very proud of
that I won't tell you what year that was
since then I have been a producer for
ABC News covering the world for many
many decades and most recently I
launched with Tina Brown in the New York
Times with Summit Series in New York
devoted to journalism sort of in its raw
form interviews on a stage illuminate
illuminating the global issues of our
time through the prism of narratives
it's called women in the world it's a
three-day summit at Lincoln Center every
April it also travels the world but
perhaps some of you will join us next
April that would be terrific now why I'm
here tonight is I'm very proud to be
back at Yale this year as a pointer
fellow in residence and what we've done
this year is launching a new initiative
under the auspices of our chair the
Pointer chair Eileen O'Connor
Eileen and I actually began at ABC many
many many years ago
Eileen's career skyrocketed and someday
I hope we put her on a stage to be
interviewed for a pointer interview her
story is incredible
but we decided to look at what we think
is an era that is unlike any other for
journalism and for much more than
journalism journalism is on the brink as
we see it sap based journalism in
particular is in crisis as we see it and
we launched a series of symposia
starting last fall and an entire new
initiative called truth in the Internet
age last fall we began with a symposium
on politics the night after the election
and tonight is our second symposium
looking at science one of your great
professors jacked a video has said that
stocks have become less sacred I think
in fact you'll hear about him say that
one of the videos tonight what does that
mean not just for journalism what does
it mean for science and what does it
mean for the institutions that define
democracy we want to tell you that
this is not only just the second
symposia that we intend to do as a part
of this initiative on truth we're going
to expand next fall and we intend to
look at the broader questions of truth
of trust and institutions of what many
perceive as a decline in trust in
institutions and what that means for
democracy itself it's going to be a
broad-based initiative involving many of
the disciplines at Yale and stay tuned
even if you're graduating we'd like you
to come back and be a part of this we
think it's going to be very important
and exciting and it's going to involve a
lot of Yale so this is a part of that
initiative as it grows welcome tonight
tonight a science we are so honored to
have the legendary Dan kahan and Meg
Yuri and of course David Hassler are
great professors interviewed by Carl
Zimmer who happens to be a Yalie and he
is also the author the columnist is you
you may all read a big column mater in
the New York Times he is one of our
interviewers and the other is Alison
Schneider a colleague of mine from way
back to the World Science Festival who
then went on to Washington Post live
Allison has just begun to launch a
science initiative at HBO's so we're
very glad to have Allison here also as
an interviewer before we begin I have a
few thank-yous the first to Eileen who
said we had to do this and that's why
we're all here in Eileen's right we had
to do this before this year got out
particularly with the science March
coming up we want to thank Mattie
Colbert Mattie is still an undergraduate
but she's been working without PA and
Mattie as some of you know is also the
editor of the politic and has helped us
with facts and with the videos tonight
we want to thank Lee Faulkner who helped
us with the videos tonight who is
wonderful and gracious Staci Bonet who
helps us in ways you can't imagine
Karen Pierce who is an executive at OPA
and extremely supportive of this
initiative we want to thank Lauren herd
Elena Pritchard and bliss Bernarda who
put on all these events and are just
astonishing and prose this was done very
less than and they showed tremendous
grace and two more I want to mention one
is Bill Hathaway many of you know bill
bill has been our pooh-bah in this
initiative and will continue to be he's
pressing us on
to expand us and to consider the issue
of trust and what it means for
institutions and builds been a big
mentor to all of us and finally I want
to thank somebody to Micah sounds like
the Oscars but we're not doing this at
the end we're doing it now so they all
get credit you're going to see some good
videos tonight and they were all done
very quickly they were the same produced
by the same woman who did our videos
last fall her name is Karen shed
she's a Woodbridge scholar this year she
graduated last year she's an extremely
talented the producer nice say that
having been at ABC a long time this is a
great talent she's poured her heart into
this Sharon would you stand up for one
minute now because no one's going to see
you from now on I'm very proud of her
so I did I also want to tell you all its
chap night it would be we think a bigger
audience if it weren't so we're going to
do this some more and we're going to
call on all you scientists again but
this is a wonderful crowd we're thrilled
you're here and there will be QA at the
last half-hour of this event so please
don't leave us you'll have a chance to
add some questions not during the
interviews but we'll bring back
everybody for the last half hour for Q&A
so we're going to get going thank you
all for being here
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you
thanks for coming out tonight my name is
Carl Zimmer and I'm speaking with David
half third he's a professor of neurology
professor containing amino biology
excuse me
and also the neurologist in chief at the
uneven Hospital
so David's area of expertise across this
and so I thought well this is you know
an event about you know truth in the age
of the internet so I thought what would
happen if I went on the internet to find
out about multiple sclerosis to what
sort of truth would I find there and
kind of scary I have to say yeah I
learned for example about how somebody
cured herself with the Paleo diet
apparently that's that's a cure just in
case you didn't know I didn't okay well
I'm just filling you in it because could
be yeah what I but I have more truth
also just so you know I learned about
something perhaps you had to be a
encountered people talking about the
liberation therapy where you're supposed
to uncork the blood vessels coming out
of your brain and oh yeah Elian so right
so and and this was a twenty million
dollar clinical trial to show that
wasn't right yeah
well and and what was interesting to me
was that that was something that was put
forward I think in 2009 and then rebuked
not long after that it was buzzing
around social media last year like crazy
it was it was back again on the Internet
these things just don't go away
and I'm just wondering what how is the
internet affected your experience as a
doctor trying to help people to
understand multiple sclerosis when
people are going suddenly this this huge
ocean of information that they can go to
instead well the first thing I say to
patients is that you should read
whatever you like to read and I my job
is to educate you and I tell them that
it's okay to read the Internet and and
read what you want but you don't have to
because there's nothing you're going to
read on the internet that I won't know
about
probably this real it reminds me of a
book by Lewis Thomas or live of the cell
Menace nailed Medusa and Thomas who was
a great scientist Dean at NYU and the
poet wrote that when he had a cardiac
arrhythmia
he had the pacemaker is put in the
doctors all came the house officers and
gave him all the literature on it and he
thanked them very much but then put the
literature into it into the saw draw and
said to himself I want to have faith in
my doctor that I don't need to read
about it that I need to have faith in
the healer and I think my job as a
physician is to have the patient to have
faith in me but for me to understand
their belief structures so many patients
most patients come in with some idea of
what may have triggered their disease
whatever it might be and they deeply
believe it because everyone looks for
causation everyone looks we're all
scientist and if something happens you
look for causation and whatever it might
have happened that occurred just before
the disease began there logically as
they should believe that it may have
caused who caused the problem ms
rheumatory fries whatever the problem
and it's not my job to take their belief
structure away it's for me to understand
their belief structure and get them on
the right medication because we have
spectacular medications now and it
reminds me of a story when I was a
freshman in college I went to Emory
College and it's still something I I
think of all the time and it was
beginning of the it was toward the end
of the year and the high school students
were accepted and they came to the
College for the second look I'm thinking
we're even now we're just doing that now
here you and I met
was an attractive young lady and we
started to talk nothing was going to
happen I was too even experienced know
what to do anyway but we started to talk
and she was a Southern Baptist and she
had her belief structure by religion and
she had never met a Jewish atheist
before from New York and we started to
have a discussion about religion now I'm
sure if I were to meet this this woman
now that she would have changed her
belief structure from what it was then
because she wanted to explore but she
was 16 she wasn't ready to lose her
belief structure but I was good and
piece-by-piece I began to disassemble
her belief structure and I watched in
front of me as his young young girl
began to I mean why we on earth there's
no heaven I mean I'm going to die and
well and she just started to fall apart
in front of me and I realized my job on
earth is not to take away someone's
beliefs structure and same with patience
my job is not to take away their belief
structure
I've gotten on my knees and prayed to
Jesus if someone that's what they
believe in that's that's my role so my I
try to understand their belief structure
and within that to get him to the right
place you have defined that the way
people think about truth and and what
truth means and how you find out truth
did you find out that that's changed in
recent years do you think well I'll say
two things of course the internet when
we want to go to the source we go to
Wikipedia I use Wikipedia it's extremely
useful so you one half used to have to
go to library you should take a lot of
work to get primary literature to get
literature now everyone has full access
to it but without necessarily having the
tools to understand what's true or not
true what died I mean it is science
isn't art its you it takes time to
understand scientific method but the
problem I have
some me ask all of you question to
ponder for a moment and his science
about truth
his science about facts we heard before
that Darwin if you looked at how many
fossils to prove I don't think science
is about facts and truth and for the
following reason so we take a pin so
anyone what's acceleration of that pet
exactly is that fact is that a fact is
that absolute truth well every time
anyone's measured it probably been that
assuming it's a vacuum for any physics
majors it put a man on the moon but for
and it was work for big particles moving
very slowly but for very small particles
approaching the speed of light
getting into Einstein relativity
Newtonian physics totally falls apart is
no longer true or it no longer works so
does that make Newtonian physics wrong
not a fact I don't think so it'd be
epitomizes what we do as a scientist
which is we create models we create
models in the laboratory biologic models
that's what we do if you want truth if
you want to fact then you do theology do
mathematics do politics listen to to our
president that's absolute truth but to
get to I just don't think we do too I
think it's important because we just
heard about global warming
so a individuals with deep religiosity
whatever the religion did and Orthodox
or they have something written down and
everything is true they read it and it
defines what truth is for them and they
want signs of me the same way they
wanted to be the same hard truth and so
if someone says well this doesn't fit
into natural selections and Darwin
theory they want to throw the whole
thing out and say it's not true but
it's not true to begin with it's the
model and our models have gotten really
really good but I think we have to
explain to the public that what we do is
create models to predict the future
but the models of revised technology
proves and and and the models keep
changing because they want act right
well what's interesting is that you're a
scientist and a doctor so you are
dealing with you know scientific
exploration and then you also deal with
patients and I mean I go to my doctor I
want the facts I want the truth you know
that's what I want and and can you
handle the truth probably not but I mean
at least some sort of certainty and and
I wonder if maybe the reason that
sometimes stuff say on the Internet can
be so appealing and gain so much
traction is because it's presented with
so much certainty this is how you care
what care multiple sclerosis they're
lying to you this is how it works to
drug industry trying to keep video right
and here is the truth and we've got the
truth for you so my job as a physician
more than anything else is to be an
educator I have to present to them
whatever they believe is fine but then
I'll present here the numbers no drug
works for everybody there isn't medicine
doesn't have the for that type of
precision and I have to teach them
uncertainty as part of my role as a
physician I wish we stopped teaching
calculus in high school and taught
statistics and said because that is
remember Johnny Carson when his last
monologues it was they're just beginning
to have these lotteries around the
country and you know quite a brilliant
comedian and his line was what people
don't understand about the lottery is
that one in a million and one in zero is
a same number and I used that line yeah
but I have to teach probability
I can't live it because once I live if I
say well this is his we have a new drug
for MS its dramatic ninety-eight percent
decrease in tak right but I have to
explain that that means two percent the
patients and they not work and so I I
have to teach other certainty to patient
and it's very easy for someone to zero
and I'm somebody in the two percent and
be like look this doesn't work I mean
that actually makes me leads me to
another question I have you know I'm one
of two representatives representatives
of journalism here tonight and and I do
wonder you know if we are talking about
issues about you know science undersea
truth in the age of the internet like in
terms of medicine for example I mean how
do you feel that journalism has helped
or hurt the process of the public
understanding the issues I mean what's
your feeling about how the research that
you and others do finally makes it out
to the TV news or the newspaper or so on
I think use journalists have gotten
better I'll give you that okay
ELISA till recently but the back in the
80s let's take the field of MS every
three weeks someone cured the disease by
doing something in the mouse mouse model
is important they're very important are
they try some drug an amount balance
whatever symptoms of MS and the mouse
right get better get better but of
course you created a model so you know
what did it
and I remember pictures of colleagues of
mine from other schools on the west
coast with curing MS and we listened to
sit really but they would do that it
sold newspapers people like the simple
stories but I give it to the media that
somewhere along the line at least they
were the real media began to say no
we're not going to do that anymore you
cure we've cured cancer and in mice and
NASA we're not going to end instead they
wanted clinical trials and I think it's
gotten much better
and because the medicines gotten better
I mean well I think that things would do
in a laboratory now it was unimaginable
a few years ago so I've often did it so
I gave it big talk the American Academy
Neurology last year and in the title was
the cause of multiple sclerosis so I was
being able provocative man yeah well and
then of course the questions what it
mean by cause I mean can you it would
since I don't believe in truth how I
believed I know the cause right and it
was based on a lecture I had to gave at
the University of Vermont about a year
earlier and I was so proud of myself we
had a big article coming any that just
coming out in nature mapping the genes
and what they do and there was a new
drug coming out that really appeared to
work that's it in with our scientific
and it was just it was a really nice
story I presented and at the end a
graduate student the back of the room
raised her hands and dr. Hoffman this is
all very nice but what good is it
Yuri knew multiple sclerosis was an
autoimmune disease you already knew that
is that it I thought it up what it
really was what good of you if it we do
everything we're ready do and talking
about someone raining on your parade
I was just dumbstruck I looked at her
and I thought that but being the showman
no a scientist you you end up you know
you perform on the stage and I had
looked at her I said AHA you're totally
right the fact that the fundamental
genetics the epigenetics the animal
models but most important to clinical
trials all give the same answer doesn't
mean that we have a good working models
what causes ms most importantly the
clinical trial confirms what we found
scientifically so maybe allows us to say
that we kind of what may cause MS but do
I know it of course not how can I ever
know absolute truth
I think models
and the fact that all the models suggest
that it's true more importantly that
thing doesn't matter if it's true what
matters is if the drugs work that isn't
isn't that good and so it made me begin
to rethink the whole problem that about
models and doesn't matter if it's true
or not at the end of the day as a
physician I just want to help patients
well that's interesting you're you're
you're describing something where you're
trying to you're trying to explain
yourself you're trying to convey the the
science of what the science says as a
scientist and I'm wondering how do you
how do you feel that scientists are
doing these days through communicating
what what they're doing you know setting
aside the journalist from setting inside
the the you know various websites I mean
so for scientists themselves when
they're trying to engage the public I
mean we're going to be having a big
march on science for science on Saturday
which is which is all about scientists
speaking up how do you think scientists
are doing I don't think we do too well
we tend to be in our little silos and we
tend not to come out we as a physician
one has a wonderful opportunity of
explaining one science to patients day
in and day out and that really allows us
I think to develop a narrative about
what we do but most scientists are not
really interested in explaining or what
they do and I don't think we communicate
it well I think people expect too much
from the science again they want us to
give the truth give a definitive answer
and we we don't we don't know can't
really do that at one level and then we
can be picked apart ie with climate
because someone doesn't agree with this
and the state is here and how do you
know that and then well if if the Bible
is right then everything's wrong but
it's a model I don't think we
communicate that and hard to communicate
ya know don't need to tell me and I'm
well aware yeah I mean but you also have
to go to politicians
and talk to them about things like
policy you know if you want to go and
ask for five million bucks to do the
next study and you start talking about
how you know we're not really in the
business of truth or what have you
like I mean these politicians are going
to probably maybe not come away with the
impression you want I mean how do you
have a scientist engage with politicians
well lissa could be a nice budget while
what what we have done in the field of
autoimmunity cancer would checkpoint
inhibitors is nothing short of
spectacular I think the reason why
government society invest in us and the
Medical Sciences because they want
treatments for disease I think the
narrative needs to be about what we've
accomplished the technology we have now
if if I was impressed sit in front of
Congress next to Collins arguing for an
arch budget you asked me I feel about
science and truth is one thing but the
narrative needs to be about what we've
accomplished because based on the models
we've created I mean cancer metastatic
melanoma used to have a 5-year survival
rate of 1% it's now 70% I presented a
patient to the first year at Yale
medical students on on Monday it was a
patient with a brain tumor not my
patient but using a drug that helped
develop and I was at Harvard anti pd-1
there's a new checkpoint inhibitor for
cancer and he's now four years out they
had told him to quit work because no one
lives past a year and a half and there
was four years out and I mean you almost
never see that I began to cry I had met
him before and I heard his narrative and
say my god
look what we've done she weeks early we
had an MS patients received this new
drug
she totally symptom free now a year out
that's narrative we need to be pigs
explaining I think to the Congress about
what we're doing now
two different pieces one is my
philosophical belief of what we do as a
scientist but then as a physician when I
communicate I mean what's your feeling
about what's coming out of Washington
these days you know with you know the
president meeting with a vaccine denier
and things like that it's you know I
mean it gets back to causality come the
flu seasons the residents present cases
every morning and come when they're
weren't getting vaccinated they start
each case with so-and-so receives a flu
vaccine and then BOOM and I point out
you know like everyone just got the flu
vaccine again we look for causality so
you can understand why a parent
watch as a child get a vaccine they have
a reaction to it
true-true unrelated so it's a natural
human tendency to want to find causality
and it's very hard it's it's because
it's a belief structure and we can do
all the experiments we want but if you
watch your child develop autism become
autistic two months after a bad reaction
to vaccine in your heart of hearts and
we have to understand that we have to
understand their belief structure but
it's hard and that's that's the problem
by having a president who understand
science and has some fundamental feeling
of what we do and why we do it I think
would be very helpful
to say the least in the indeed what and
what about just real quickly well where
do you see the future for for medical
research in terms of you know building
on these big successes I mean where
where do the resources have to go now
and how do you persuade people that this
will bear fruit in the future I mean we
are is biology now where we're I think
Justin was back in the 1600s
we've just a possibly we just made the
periodic table
which is a sequence of the human genome
and again we're doing things now they're
unimaginable even six months ago and we
need to convey the excitement of where
we are that we are solving problems we
are solving disease it's a golden era in
medicine and let's not let it stop that
I believe is a narrative okay all right
well thank you David
very good
[Applause]
[Music]
how did America rise up from a backwoods
country to be one of the greatest
nations the world has ever known
we pioneered industries and all this
required the greatest innovations in
science and technology in the world and
so science is a fundamental part of the
country that we are but in this the 21st
century when it comes time to make
decisions about science it seems to me
people have lost the ability to judge
what is true and what is not what is
reliable what is not reliable
what should you believe what should you
not believe and when you have people who
don't know much about science standing
in denial of it and rising to power that
is a recipe for the complete dismantling
of our informed democracy let us demand
that educators around America teach
evolution not as fact but his theory an
increasing number of parents showing
skepticism about vaccinations voters
have approved a ban on GMOs climate
change unproven science that's not the
country I remember growing up in not
that we didn't have challenges
I'm old enough to remember the 60s and
the 70s got a hot war in a cold war
civil rights movement and all this was
going on but I don't remember any time
where people were standing in denial of
what science was one of the great things
about science is that it is an entire
exercise in finding what is true the
hypothesis you tested I get a result a
rival of mine double checks it because
they think I might be wrong they perform
an even better experiment that I did and
they find out any this experiment
matches oh my gosh we're onto something
here and out of this arises a new emerge
into the truth it does it better than
anything else we have ever come up with
and as human beings
this is science it's not a toy with
it's not something to say I choose not
to believe equals mc-squared
you don't have that option when you have
an established scientific emergent truth
it is true whether or not you believe in
it and the sooner you understand that
the faster we can get on with the
political conversations about how to
solve the problems that face us so once
you understand that humans are warming
the planet you can then have a political
conversation about that you can say well
should we are the carbon credits do we
do this do we put a tariff on it do we
fund do we subsidize those those have
political answers and every minute one
is in denial you are delaying the
political solution that should have been
established years ago
as a voter as a citizen scientific
issues will come before you and isn't it
worth it to say all right let me at
least become scientifically literate so
I can think about these issues and act
intelligently upon recognize what
science is and allow it to be what it
can and should be in the service of
civilization it's in our hands
hi I'm Alison Schneider from access and
this is Meg Gary here from Yale I don't
know if we're going to be as dramatic no
I have about - that's whatever uh her
title and here at Yale is up on the
board so I won't repeat that but you're
known for your work on the coevolution
of black holes and galaxies and also for
being a outspoken advocate for gender
equality in science and academia at
large so so excited to be here with you
and to talk about this and I wanted to
start by actually just asking you about
that call to arms and sort of whether in
general you agree the sentiment that
science is under siege and yeah I I
don't think I really liked hearing that
actually Neil's a friend of mine and I
haven't heard that piece and he's I
think he said it incredibly well we're
in a world where more than ever we need
scientific knowledge expertise we need
to solve really difficult problems big
challenges ahead most of which will
require some kind of scientific
innovation and and yet we're in a world
that is doesn't value knowledge
particularly or in a moment should I say
in a moment where where knowledge is is
subvert 'add to other kinds of power
something like that so it's a moment
when science is not being honored let's
say as it might be but on the other hand
you know he's talking about it we're all
talking about it we're all in our labs
doing research and learning things so so
I don't know if I'd say we're under
siege exactly we may have to make an
effort to justify what we're doing he
seems maybe at the end there calls for a
scientific literacy not higher education
but scientific literacy and so I thought
it'd be interesting for me to take about
three three words that scientists use
and the public use in very different
ways
maybe starting with Siri mm-hmm
it's one that now is vice president
pence said in the video that we should
teach evolution as a theory rather than
fact
um this can pack that elaborate
resources well first of all it is a
theory okay evolution is a theory of how
nature progresses and one funny thing
about theories is we can only ever prove
they're wrong we can't prove they're
correct they're correct
against some tests but there might be a
further test you know that they fail in
the future so so he's correct that it's
a theory but the public uses the word
theory to mean not quite real right if
you say well in theory you know you
could run a ten second hundred yard dash
what they mean is you couldn't possibly
run a ten second hundred yard dash so so
I think we yeah I think we misunderstand
sometimes what means what I mean
scientists we can only come up with
ideas and test them we can't really
prove anything to be true we can prove
things to be wrong okay think that's
really confusing to you right like the
idea that you're not proving something
but you're disproving it yeah that sort
of see in there I think maybe is that
something this isn't isn't I don't think
it's well understood actually I think
science if I think back to how I was
taught science it's mostly taught as a
assemblage of facts right and sometimes
it's taught as a very rigid you know
what is your hypothesis and what is your
test of your hypothesis and so on it's
not really the living breathing thing
that that science is which is developing
knowledge we're trying to understand you
know how nature works and I think the
really key point about science if I
could hijack your your question a little
bit is that we don't have the answers
nature does so we interrogate nature you
know we we ask to sell how it works or
ask the black hole how much you know
we're trying to observe the black hole
to figure out how much stuff it's eaten
up but but but even
we wanted the answer to be one thing it
is whatever it is so we don't it's not a
set of beliefs we can choose I think
David earlier mentioned that people ask
too much from science would you agree
with that that you know when you say I
don't know
that's the cola reading but yeah yeah I
well I certainly yeah I think scientists
we tend to hedge because we can't say
with a certainty we can't say anything
with certainty if there we know anything
it's that nothing is certain okay it's
uh we could say it's highly probable and
maybe for you it's good enough that it's
99% likely or 99.99% likely but we can't
say it's a hundred percent ever but so
it's what I think is it's journalists
and I mean maybe a carlos lehder too but
I think one of those things that you
struggle with is how to convey that
uncertainty right in a responsible way
and so it is but it's qualifiable that's
the thing right about certain
uncertainty so how do you how can you
better you me that are sort of I guess
convey that to people communicate that
to people that's a really good question
I think well one one approach is just to
just to dance around it that is all of
the all of the careful way scientists
speak when they're speaking to their
colleagues maybe we don't need to do
that when we're speaking to the public
maybe we can we can not dwell on what
percentage correct is this I mean that's
one option the other option would be to
try to teach people probability is as
secondary first ed or or you know hope
that they understand better what an
uncertainty is and how well we've
measured something in physics you know
we're very precise about all this stuff
we measure exactly you know the upper
limit to the dipole moment of the
electron or something to some precision
of twenty orders of magnitude but I mean
significant figures is what I meant but
you know does that signify to people I
don't know I don't know if it does
right um what about when we make mistake
because I thought that yeah what well I
mean all humans make mistakes and I
think mistakes are normal maybe the more
pernicious thing is is when it's
deliberate right science has had its
share of scandals we they're not maybe
that we don't have tons of them but we
do have people who cheat occasionally
but that was a thing Neil said actually
a minute ago was that every result gets
tested by somebody and if they can't
verify your result then it doesn't hold
up so science maybe is one of those
areas where cheaters really don't
prosper
maybe mistake seems right word may be it
how do you convey to people I guess or
how do we better convey to people that
is that is incremental ah the
incremental nature and sort of that you
might find one thing and you might
observe something else in a different
context and under different constraints
and hats so people are getting I think
coming and looking for maybe not a
hard-and-fast truth but it's but an
answer and so how do you can I guess
convey that how can how can generalist
better convey it I think they're the
right thing to do is just give people
the detail I mean there is a reason if
you if two experiments get a different
result
then it's either in the statistics that
you expected or it's in the parameters
of the experiment being different
those aren't hard I mean again I think
Neil fit - we're all scientists at heart
I mean that is we we start out asking
you know we do comparisons all the time
we do comparisons all the time so that's
that's the method and if you can say
okay these things differed only in one
aspect and they got different results
then it must be that aspect that made
the difference everybody gets that we do
think logically many many humans think
logically I think we can explain those
things so what's happening what's going
on in terms of Sciences and is it
affecting your work in particular and
how and how you when you're in a good
question um
so to the first question why is there
this moment when somehow scientists who
before were on a pedestal and their
every word was guiding you know
countries nations I think hmm I think
it's because people misunderstand
sometimes misunderstands science as just
another set of beliefs so you know we
heard the story of the young woman who
is a Baptist and you know the young
Jewish atheist must know different sets
of beliefs and people think well maybe
science is just yet another set of
beliefs that you can choose to believe
or not I mean I have seen that reaction
from people who who are not themselves
scientists and I think we just have to
reiterate that we don't choose the
answer we don't choose the set of
beliefs we might have preferences but in
the end nature decides so it's simple
there's a quote which we were talking
about yesterday but science doesn't care
what you believe
yes exactly
can i I want to ask you the same
question actually that Carl had asked I
have such a have to learn about the the
role of the press and sort of how we how
we help scientist and how we hurt them
well you know as a consumer of excellent
science writing I think you guys have
ulis job I can't count the number of
times I've talked to a reporter and I'm
sure they've talked to a dozen other
people and I give them some you know 30
minutes of heavy dump of a lot of
information and I then I read an article
that is perfectly formed and explains
things much nicer than I did and makes
it all very understandable so I think
it's like an essential I think it's
fabulous what what science writers do
and we're in some ways the momment
arguably changing but you know we're
sort of the way they convey to them to
the larger public what's happening and
do you think that the relationship
between Congress and just the funding of
science more more broadly and the press
and satin scientists themselves likes to
do the
or media science everyone do they tend
to do better when it when it comes to
funding if their comment says well I'm
in astrophysics emigrate let's put it
that way you know if you fight cancer
maybe it's a little easier I don't know
I think funding for science is becoming
more difficult this is maybe a part of
the a general trend and whether it's
related I'm not sure I think it's more
related to the fact that you know in
World War two scientists physicists in
particular were pretty helpful to the
war effort
man we're coming up with radar bomb etc
and a grateful nation then funded saw
science as a valuable thing and funded
it furthermore today's economy you know
the 21st century economy runs on physics
discoveries from a hundred years ago so
in a sense you know it's very clear that
the investment in fundamental knowledge
leads to good things for the nation the
trouble is that the people making the
decisions don't always make that
connection and once the Cold War sort of
ended then the imperative for funding
science started to weaken and I think
we're in a state now where people are
really attuned to very short term
returns and science doesn't tend to
return things quickly there's huge
investments of time to to make this
incremental gains and maybe occasionally
a big breakthrough it's not easy work
and so when you say okay what did those
what did those five grants produce maybe
nothing but maybe five other grants that
we're never supposed to produce
something did or whatever it's very it's
hard to predict where the where the
progress will be made and I think we
have to just see it as an investment in
our future in solving future problems
how do we better so the way we get we
walk around with the fruits of those
labors in our pockets and you know in
our body
sorry and so I have how can you get
people to better understand that I guess
that's that pace okay it's a good point
you know
I I was talking to a class of Yale
freshmen who you know the audience knows
are really really smart I hope some of
you out there and and we were talking
about different kinds of scientific
research and they were saying you know I
really like this stuff is great you know
it's great you study planets around
other stars and it's wonderful to hear
about you know the motions of the
continents before they were as they are
today blah blah blah but the only thing
really worth funding is medical research
because we all you know we all have
health problems and that applies to
everybody and that seems like the right
thing to fund and I said oh that's very
interesting I said what happens if a
person has cancer for example well they
get radiation treatment or they have a
drug treatment or they have diagnosis
with imaging right diagnostic imaging
most of those machines most of the
things that are used to treat illness
most of the technical stuff was figured
out a long time ago in some totally not
applied way in some physics lab or some
engineering lab nothing to do with
biology biological research so you need
both you need all of the enterprise in
order to have a healthy response to
problems like illness or whatever you're
an astrophysicist you work in a very
sort of on spiring field and I'm well so
at one question actually when you are
you know when you're at his dinner or
you're in the airport and you need
somebody and you tell them you're an
astrophysicist how do you wait what's
the what's the typical reaction I don't
know whether I should answer this way
but I will so when I was younger and I
was on an airplane and somebody asked me
that question like what do you do I
actually chose if I had a lot of work to
do I would tell them I was an
astrophysicist and then they would just
kind of say oh you must be really smart
or something you know they would kind of
like not talk to me and if I didn't mind
having a chat and I would say I was an
astronomer and then they'd ask me lots
of questions
that's really funny but so but I guess
it's the barriers I didn't think I was
an astrologer we didn't what some of
them did that's even dance anyway well
yeah um but I'd like the barrier but I
think did they ever
sort of wear it like a badge of honor I
sometimes hear like people wear as a
badge of honor that they don't
understand science they oh you know I
was never good at math and all right
yeah yeah I I don't know I see that as a
reaction that's more just because
they're a little intimidated maybe by
the by the words or something but I
think everybody I talked to I can
explain anything to actually I I you
know I write a little bit of science I
don't do much of it but I I wrote an
article on the Higgs boson for for CNN
and the Higgs boson is hard to
understand it's like a not a really a
particle kind of a particle kind of a
feel what is it and I thought I just I
have to make this understandable for
anybody you know whether they had
science classes or not and I think we
can do I mean that must be you're a
science journalist you must believe that
or you couldn't do what you do yeah but
it's but it again but it's difficult and
I think but so you but you to your
points are also about having and want to
ask you about having direct sort of ways
to communicate and engage with public
what are scientists a doing a good job
of it are they doing enough of it and
how could they be better at that
particularly in the field like yours
where you know that the work is very
complex it's very expensive as
experiments they're not replicable
they're not I mean how how how skew how
do you do that yeah well I fortunate
enough to work in a field where we have
a lot of interesting stories to tell and
a lot of beautiful images to show and
it's actually easier I would say then
there maybe some of the more esoteric
fields where you are really down in the
subatomic world where you can't really
yeah once you can show pictures there
too but look I think we do a lot of it
we a lot of scientists are trying to
communicate there
work we need to do it better and we need
to do more of it I think it's wait for
too long we've been kind of behind a
wall just leave us alone let us do our
work
keep the please keep the tax funds
coming you know tax payers funding
coming and not feeling any obligation to
kind of report back and that's changed I
would say most young scientists are on
Twitter and their tweet about their
science for example these the ones I
know so I think we need to do more
communication than we have in the past
and we need to do we need to learn how
to do the communication right I guess
Dan will talk later about this whole way
that scientists misunderstand their
audience and what we talking about so we
need to learn that stuff so scientists
on Twitter and alongside a very sort of
old peer-review tenure you know system
how does the - how does that go yeah
there is a generational divide
I'm on the I'm on the old side of that
divide and I you know I'm not I don't
spend a lot of time on Twitter either
but but I do see how it works and how
you know how it connects people who
might otherwise not have a clue to even
listen to you
so look who said let a thousand flowers
bloom so there are different ways of
communicating and let's all take our
shot at it but one thing we have to do
is we have to explain to people what
science does for them I mean we haven't
really talked about that that that as we
go in the future it's only going to get
more and more critical to understand
science think of people who are in
Congress people who sit on the courts
very few of them have a scientific
background very few of them know
anything about science and yet most of
the issues they consider have a
scientific or technical aspect that
really begs to be understood we have a
minute and a half so I have one question
this is the March for Sciences this
weekend one of the
you know principles or goals as
diversity in science obviously something
you care a lot about you're passionate
about it has it gotten any better
oh yeah oh why why is that and um well
uh why that's a really good question I
think people just understand that if you
don't include all the talent you are
basically dumbing down your field and
there's a lot of talent out there that
doesn't look like what Yale looked like
50 years ago for example so we are you
know change change is kind of hard to to
avoid could we get there faster yes and
you know when I was a kid medicine and
physics both had about 10% of
practitioners were women of that order
now medicine is more than half women in
the medical school graduating class of
more than half women and physics is
inched up to 20% 20% at the
undergraduate er the PhD level so could
it be better and faster sure yeah
absolutely and I think the world would
be better for it that's the most
important part the world the science
would be better if we had a full include
fully inclusive profession I'm going to
do it without 10 20 seconds left we're
into it thank you so much I am and the
next one Carl come back and say thank
you
you
people recall a fax fundamentally is
impacted by a frame a psychological
frame and we see that in lots of
different contexts in terms of people's
beliefs and interpretations about facts
actually I think a lot of us who are
more educated and spend time doing this
work we think well we ingest show the
person to study or we can just show the
person that hey this is evidence that it
rained yesterday you know obviously
their mind will be changed we will be
able to move forward and make policy and
we've got so much social science that
shows that that's just not true if I
think of you as a member of my group
whatever that group is I automatically
trust you more I like you more I think
you're smarter I will sacrifice for you
that's how we evolved you know I'm a
this kind of person I'm a this sort of
political party a person who supports
this candidate when we feel that way our
psychologies do something different they
don't use the normal processes of
critical thinking and evaluating
evidence they use a different set of
processes that are about thinking and
learning from your in-group that tends
to perpetuate itself because if I just
see myself as different from the group
I'm going to begin to see my group is
better and the other group is worse I am
going to now look for information in my
environment that supports that my group
is better than the other group is worse
I'm going to when I have the resources
and the power promote my group at the
expense of the other group and we create
a reality that is actually one of
conflict but one we believe to be
absolutely true and right
you
so I've known
for some time and as a science writer
who writes a lot about things like
evolution or climate change and gets
lots of letters I have often thought to
myself what's going on when I'm writing
something and somebody reads it what's
what's happening at the other end and
it's always seems a kind of mysterious
thing and so when I met Dan I insisted
that we have lunch fairly regularly so I
can pick your brain to understand what's
going on and it's been really helpful
for me as a journalist although I always
say like well what do I do next and
you're like I don't know so I'm on my
own I understand but but maybe we could
sort of just start by following up on
what they were saying in there because
it's such a it's such a key thing that I
find myself sometimes having to re
explain to scientists because there's a
I really is a fundamental tenet I think
among a lot of scientists who say like
well if there's any sort of problem
having to do with science I just need to
just give some more data and it'll be
okay if somebody doesn't seem to quite
understand what I'm saying well here let
me push some more information on them
and that'll solve the problem so so how
do you know that that doesn't solve the
problem well on the issues where people
aren't divided about science issues
which are orders of magnitude larger
than the set on which there they are
polarized they don't know anything more
about the science it's not that the
scientists who are biologists came along
and explained pasteurization of milk so
much better than the climate scientists
have been able to explain the greenhouse
effect and I studied a scientist science
communication we have facts they're
provisional and incremental too but they
usually are about many of them are
startling to members of the public and
even to scientists and one of them is
that the people who are most divided
among these politically divisive issues
like climate change they're not stupid
they're the smartest people they're the
people who do the best on valid science
literacy tests so I guess so when you so
when you're looking at people and you're
you you do you you you gather this data
and you're finding that you're looking
at how much people know like what do you
call like a scientific intelligence
scores and there are all kinds of
measures of critical reasoning capacity
that are looking at whether people have
the thinking skills that are necessary
to make sense of scientific evidence and
it's a very robust finding that on the
issues in which we have polarization the
people who score the best on those
various kinds of assessments are always
the most polarized polarized on cultural
grounds or political grounds when
there's that kind of conflict about an
issue people aren't using their reason
to try to figure out what's true they're
using their reason to make sure that
they cultivate the right kind of
orientation towards those issues because
at that point their peers are going to
see their the positions they take as a
kind of badge of membership or loyalty
or even even social competence um that
doesn't happen if that's the much wider
span of issues so wide and so taking for
granted that we don't even think about
them people who are the highest in
science literacy converge on those and
they bring along a lot of other people
from their group so that's a really
important thing to understand about this
dynamic of course we should have the
best science education that we can
possibly give people I mean it will make
them them better off but that's not the
cause of the kinds of conflicts that we
do have over things like climate change
yeah well let's focus on climate change
we had that before in the video so
what's the group identity that is so
fierce that people would get up in arms
about radiative forcing or the
circulation on the straddle actually
most what's the identity issue engine
most people of any identity would have
no idea what you just were talking about
they have a position on climate change
beliefs are things that help you to
engage in action um and the beliefs that
they
forming are the ones that are going to
impel them to strike the right kind of
stance in their peers when those kinds
of issues come up but what are the kinds
of identities that are like that they're
myriad and also I should say too if I
have a study that looks at the kind of
group allegiances that are the
predictors in these studies of opinion
on these kinds of issues those are
models too sometimes you use simple
right-left continua continuum and that's
good enough you might say well maybe we
need twice as much explanatory power is
that so let's have a two by two but
those are all just models they're kind
of like the board Rutherford Adam if
that's a way that will help you to get
some traction and explaining and
predicting and maybe prescribing ways in
which people can get out of these
disputes use them but in fact there are
members of all kinds of communities and
it's kind of odd that that kind of issue
could come to assume the status that it
has but that really happens I mean
that's the thing that we should be
trying to fix we don't have stupid
people we have a polluted science
communication environment in which the
the positions on certain kinds of issues
have become so entangled in in identity
that people will in fact expect other
people and judge other people who don't
they'll fit the pattern to have this
kind of position on an issue like that I
mean one thing that sort of has struck
me in terms of again with climate change
is that you know some people have almost
basically said this is that well if what
they're saying about climate change were
true then we would be required to do
politically all sorts of things that I
would never want to happen on a
political basis so so I don't so
therefore it can't be right
scientifically I mean it well but I
don't you think it went that way or is
it no well I don't think it works I mean
that might be a kind of model again the
way of rationally reconstructing how
people form these views that's certainly
not the way people think and
they would spot the obvious fallacy and
that just as readily as anybody who's
listening to us here and again it's the
people who score the highest on science
intelligent assessments are the ones who
are divided like that so I don't think
that they say well we'll just be
inconvenient to believe that therefore
I'm not going to believe it um but let's
really let's understand that there's
really not that much difference between
the climate science literacy the people
who believe in it and people who don't I
did a study that showed and it's
encouraging that 80% of the general
population knew that that carbon is a
greenhouse gas and that when humans put
it into the air that the temperature
goes up but just as high percentage
eighty percent thought that what climate
scientists were saying is that if we do
that it will kill all the vegetation on
the planet because plants won't be able
to engage in photosynthesis with all
that carbon hanging around right so if
you know that carbon is a greenhouse gas
but you think it's going to kill
everything in the greenhouse you don't
know very much about climate science and
we found that the level of comprehension
of both the causes and the consequences
of climate change were equally dismal
among people in general believed and
disbelieved in climate change the people
who got these kinds of assessments who
scored perfectly they were divided on
political grounds you you've been
working on something recently that's
interesting in the as opposed to
scientific intelligence you've been
interested that science curiosity yeah
and and maybe you could start talk about
that how you got interested in that and
and what that's what that means for for
how people can you know well understand
these issues so I'll give a model of
myself then I guess to explain something
like that but you know at some point it
becomes kind of not just boring but even
demoralizing to do these stupid human
tricks on where you show that people
will actually perform
well on math problems or evidence
interpretation if the consequence of
getting the answer right would be to put
them in opposition to a group member
reason is being demeaned and degraded by
the kinds of forces that generate that
state of affairs I can't say I was sick
of it and walked away from it but I was
certainly really excited by the idea
that my research group would do
something else which was to try to help
science documentary makers see if they
could add to their their toolkit or
maybe enhance their craft if they used
evidence-based methods and the one thing
you needed then to have those kinds of
studies was a good measure of just how
much people are interested in science
you don't want to be testing your theory
about how to make a better science
documentary by having a sample of people
who never would watch a science
documentary anyway so we developed for
that very purpose a scale that measured
basically how eager people were to learn
what science knows just for the sake of
it not for any kind of benefit they
might have but it turned out that it did
to our surprise identify people who
despite having the kind of group
identity that usually divides people
less polarized and when we saw that we
said well let's do some experiments to
see why that might be true it turned out
they were also much more even-handed
when they were engaged in search for
information it's one of the the
signature attributes of this kind of we
call motivated reasoning that generates
these disputes on the science issues
that partisans will want to consult the
sources that reinforce what they already
believe they want to make sure that
they're best able to do that and then
you kind of encounter with others but
the people would have scored high in
science curiosity they wanted to read
the stuff read the the the articles and
the papers that were actually contrary
to their view they hadn't heard about
this before and they thought that would
be interesting so people can use their
reason for lots of things I think we all
use them both to figure out something
about the world and to be good group
members these were people who if they
didn't believe in evolution they didn't
believe in it they didn't believe in
climate change so they'd believe in it
nevertheless they were using their
reason to satisfy another interest that
they had besides being good group
members which was just to understand the
kind of impressive things that other
people scientists using their reason are
able to understand about how the world
works
and that was heartening if you ask me
what can we do to persuade climate
deniers with science curiosity I'm not
sure I'm going to have an answer I just
think it's intrinsically good that we
have people or science carries so does
that does that give that the people who
are making documentaries about things
like climate change or vaccines is that
do you think it's going to be able to
give them any guidance well I certainly
make a better show you see I mean that
there's this you you need science for
communicating science just as much as
you need it for generating the insights
that science confers and I think that
all at least it there's it's a good
hypothesis that all science documentary
producers could do a better job at what
they want to do which is satisfying the
appetite of people to know what science
knows if sometimes they used evidence
based methods and what they were doing
when one clue that they might be able
that they might need it is that even
people with good professional judgment
groups of science documentary producers
they'll disagree furiously with
themselves about particular things and
so maybe if you could do an experiment
that they agree is relevant to that than
then they do it that so I think there's
a reason for people who are engaged in
science communication to want to be as
good as they can at that and to use
evidence-based methods that's
independent of whether it's going to
change the world in some way I think the
idea that you're going to get a science
documentary to solve the problem on
climate change its climate naive because
the vast majority of people aren't going
to be watching that but I don't think
the vast majority of science documentary
producers think that they're just
advocates by other
means they just like to they liked
science themselves and they liked the
idea that they can help other people to
to get the same kind of satisfaction
from knowing what science knows so if
people aren't getting that information
from a science documentary I mean what
do you think people are getting short
people get Maslin than those influence
yeah they don't in this model from the
mouths of the scientist to the ear of
the citizen it's always been wrong if
you say that JJ James Hansen they go oh
yeah that's too bad that he died we
won't have any more Muppets or something
like that they have no idea what a
climate scientist says and I feel bad
for scientists because they're taking
these disputes so personally it must be
something we said it was what you said
it has nothing to do with what they know
about science for the most part you in
very consequential science it's the
other people in their communities who
are transmitting that information to
them and they've got to be pretty good
at it these communities because if they
were out there consistently misleading
their members about what science knows
they wouldn't last very long right and
you can believe that selection effect
even if you don't believe evolution you
might get that something like that is
true and so on all the issues where we
don't have disputes people aren't
hearing scientists say something except
through a really dense network of
intermediaries so we should be trying to
figure out when we get into these
situations where there's this persistent
political conflict what's wrong with the
the intermediary processes that usually
reliably connect people to scientists
that's what I'm talking about when I say
the science communication environment
the sum total of influences
cues heuristics and what-have-you that
enable people to be able to identify
what science knows despite their
inability to do it themselves if they
then come into conflict of the sort that
we're seeing that's where the problem is
somewhere in that that network of
intermediaries there's some kind of
contamination if you want to make that
your model of science communication yeah
you mentioned that contamination you
talk about pollution before I mean are
you talking about some think tank
handing out educational brochures that
are full of misinformation I mean what's
sure and actually I think you know that
the by pollution I mean that the state
of entanglement between positions on
these kinds of issues and individuals
group identity I don't think anybody
that anybody is that good about creating
them because if they were there'd be a
lot more things about which we're in
conflict than we are so sometimes this
kind of thing just happens by accident
and actually you know one kind of
accident that can cause it is to take a
conflict like climate change and say why
is the other side so stupid that's
basically what what that that kind of
what that happens all the time and if
you say to somebody something you
believe in is a sign of stupidity and
all the other people you associate with
and rely on critically for your psychic
and material well-being or stupid to
good luck trying to convince them if you
put people in a position of having to
choose between their identity and
knowing what science knows they're going
to go with their identity and it's
plenty rational for them to do so
because what they believe about climate
doesn't affect it in any particular way
if you're an ordinary person right your
your belief doesn't affect the climate
the amount of carbon that you're
responsible for is inconsequential you
make a mistake about those things it's
not going to hurt you or anybody you
care about but you make a mistake about
what your position should be on one of
these identity defining issues you could
be in a lot of trouble so it's pretty
reasonable at that person at that point
even rational for people to follow that
kind of belief formation strategy but
that's not because they chose the
conditions they were in but that's
that's the kind of incentives we create
when we have a polluted science
communication environment so it sounds
like I mean there are all these you know
they serve like this landscape of
science issues and pretty much you know
things like pasteurization or whatever
they're not they're not these flash
points but it's it is
easy under certain circumstances force a
climate to go cool down into one of
these identity conflicts so it's easy to
go down into it yeah how do you get back
up out yeah gee I don't know you tell me
I think that there are ways out my
research group does science evidence
based science communication advising
four copies four counties in Florida
that have formed a compact to try to
pool their resources to deal with
climate issues so it's a great job so
for them I mean they're on the leading
edge of the leading edge and and elbow
you know if you talk about orion's and
and sea-level rise they've actually had
that forever
you know since Ponce de Leon I guess
made a wrong turn and ended up there and
built disney on it land on a swamp but i
don't know it's past offended they've
been bailing themselves out so they're
kind of used to that but they're also
used to just talking about it what are
we going to do
and like other other people who live in
other regions they built knowledge
factories their university system to
help them understand how to live well
there and they've got great climate
scientists and they will listen to them
I mean there are two kinds of climate
change in that that area the one that
puts the question who are you and whose
side are you want and the one that puts
the question well what do we know what
are we going to do what choices are
going to have what kinds of consequences
I mean if you ban as it were the first
in order to have the second kind of
climate change conversation then you
don't see this kind of divisiveness so I
would say one thing and it's not as
readily possible throughout the United
States as it was there is to find some
basis for using what science knows
that's completely independent from the
the cultural identity that people
otherwise have right they're divided if
you ask them about climate change and
human caused climate change there as
much as anywhere else in the country but
there are also people who are used to
tackling the kinds of problems that in
fact climate change is now magnifying
and they have good leaders who know how
to construct the converse
station that doesn't put the the
citizens in the position of having to
choose between their identity and
knowing what's known so I haven't seen
you since election day you know this is
the first time I've seen why I just came
out a couple days ago and decided you
know everybody else is trying to live
with it so I should do okay you you
unlock the door and came out of your
bunker yeah yeah I mean what I mean I
I've been thinking about you because I
mean like you know you have Scott put
talking about whether or not carbons
involves the climate changes you have
this vice president who's saying let's
teach evolution as a theory and yeah
Robert F Kennedy you know meeting with
you up I mean it's like it's like just
hitting all Dan Khan's buttons I'm
talking so like so what do you tell you
I mean I'm something like I mean this is
another another you know in fact its
provisional to but I good luck over
overturning it people aren't politically
polarized on something like vaccines we
do have these enclaves where there are
people who are hostile to vaccines and
that could even cause a public health
problem but it's not the case that oh
the Republicans they don't believe in
the utility of vaccine oh it's those
left-wing people who shop at Whole Foods
or something like that um although it
readily could become true if people
engage in a kind of discourse about it
that's recriminate or II and and filled
with contempt I mean that's the signal
that some issue is part of your team's
collection of positions so I really do
think that that we have a lot to be
concerned about with the way in which
facts are treated by the Trump
administration one of the reasons we
have to worry is that if you attack them
on it you're actually conveying a signal
that it's us versus them so I think it's
really going to be tricky to try to
oppose Trump on these specifics without
doing so in a way that could actually
add to the stock of issues
that bear these really unfortunate
meanings that divide people yeah it's a
big big problem and I'm not sure what to
do but I'm sure that I know how we
should attack the problem and that's
with more empirical testing of
communication strategies and I know lots
of people are looking at these things so
I think if we if we accustom ourselves
just as a culture in a society to use
the science of science communication
we'll probably get some some good advice
out of that we talked a little bit
before about like scientists sort of
coming out of their labs or their
offices and actually be more engaging
and I'm just wondering what you think
about how scientists do now I understand
what you're saying like oh well you know
how people think about science in their
community may not they might not get
that directly from scientists
but if scientists do become more like
Neil Tyson or or Bill Nye you know
showing up on Fox News I hope it'd make
em like Bill Nye frankly because he is
definitely a font of contempt and people
people like him because they think that
he's ridiculing and making fun of the
other side their memes about him I mean
just the other side is watching right
they know what you think of them if you
think somebody would think what Bill Nye
does is a funny thing so here's the
point there's a science of science
communication and for people who aren't
familiar with the well the facts or the
the dynamics that it has revealed to us
want to engage in science communication
all the same there's a chance that they
can actually make things worse
I think scientists want to talk to
people and explain what they're doing
that's great because there's a lot of
curious people who want to hear them but
scientists shouldn't labor under the
burden of thinking that it's all their
fault or that they're the ones who are
going to save us from this because what
scientists say again are mediated
through all
of these kinds of networks so I don't
think it's really a question of teaching
the science to get to give a better
speech although that's a good thing in
itself because there are lots of people
who'd like to hear what scientists have
to say about things all right
thank you Dad thank you
[Applause]
so less sacred you know I think that we
used to believe that there was a kind of
fact was clearly verifiable there was a
fact that you couldn't take a hundred
different views of it and now facts
attacked all the time is not being faxed
but the cost of that is that you have
the choice of isolation and putting
yourself into an environment where
there's uniform agreement about
something that may be important to you
but about which there may be controversy
if I had a belief that only one and 1000
people had I wouldn't bump into anybody
in my daily contacts who had that belief
I can now instantaneously be in contact
with 10,000 of them that's what's
different
you
okay I know I'm going to I'm going to
try and go like this I'm sorry I look
really weird we're going to take some
questions from the audience
just two mics coming around I'm going to
ask a question in the spirit of
questions and curiosity what is the
question that drives each of you what's
the big your your big question the one
in the back of the lawn on you and
you're scratching your head about well
okay how the universe works is small
this is long honking I'll watch anything
I say I'm going to tell I jumped in her
on purpose actually has something much
more complicated how do human beings
work that the it really it's two things
one is they're tied okay so for first
you know one is the mystery of how
people given the limited time that they
have and limited expertise could
possibly manage to do as well as they do
in aligning themselves with the best
evidence in science and then the other
is how come despite having that capacity
we do end up with these controversies
between people who have have different
values but not about what we should do
given the facts but just what the facts
are that's really a well it's it's
something I want to know about to try to
make a difference in the quality of our
life but it's also just a mystery that
really compels me well how the brain
works
I won't curl to answer to oh I you know
I'm a reporter on biology which means I
have an excuse to call of people and
just find out how life in general works
and I just I mean I don't I don't try to
insert it I don't get I try to keep my
answers my questions simple and yet
there's just no end of it you know it's
like every weekend just have to get on
the phone with a bunch of other people
and just be like wait how did you know
that how did you figure that out and put
it go from here but yeah so it's so yeah
maybe that's sort of one of challenges
as a science writer is that for us is
that we you know we talked to scientists
we learn about Sciences science we kind
of get it but then how do you get that
across and eight hundred a thousand
words or two I'm a Twitter a hundred
area for a character can be done I'm
sorry
there's the first questions here in the
front hello thank you for an excellent
discussion my name is Cherie I'm a
graduate student here in the
neuroscience department and on the eve
of the science March I was hoping you
could comment on it I'm actually to be
honest sort of on the fence about
whether this is a productive event I see
that the primary issues that really put
science under siege are those that are
politicized and I'm concerned that this
March might be a movement towards making
other elements of science more
politicized and therefore expanding some
of the aggressive tone that we see today
so we'd like that's a really
well-founded concern there's a kind of
dynamic kind of rope-a-dope strategy
that people who want to confuse other
people about science engage in where
they just war the person who wants to
convey scientific facts into a fight and
into a fight to where that the
characters who are
being chastised for not knowing the
facts have a really very conspicuous
kind of cultural identity and this has
happened both with evolution and climate
change they know that the content of the
arguments that are being made aren't
really the most important thing people
are going to be assimilating what
they're going to be paying attention to
is oh which side is this person on and
which side am I on
because they want to make sure that if
this is an issue of conflict they're on
the right side of it with their group so
yeah when you go to March in Washington
and say we're against Trump
then you're putting yourself in a
position where it could happen that
people would say okay it's the
scientists versus Trump it could you
know I don't know what the probability
is and I think at some point - if
they're just intrinsically moral things
to do but there is there is a risk and I
think people should think about it and
resolve it before they they do one thing
or the other so should we say were for
Trump and for science to confuse them
Wow well why actually why don't you try
this in this group yeah but but you know
on some of these issues I do think that
if somebody makes the effort to try to
understand what the evidence is and then
makes a considered judgment on something
to do that's that's the right kind of
attitude look III think dis March III if
it had been up to me I would have said
it's not a good idea because I think
it's very easy for it to become highly
politicized but I think there if if it
if it remains a conversation about what
science does for the nation for the
world and not focusing on climate change
or evolution or you know but talking
about broadly science and and stays away
from the political finger-pointing I
think it could it could be an
educational moment I mean it's really
important politics is nasty and we have
to be very careful of what we say and
not politicize science their ethical
issues talked about earlier I think
could be very very dangerous too
--eline sciences anti-trump at the end
of the day I find it interesting we've
talked a lot about oh in my world about
the Obamacare the council's the Care Act
and friends who voted for Trump have a
home on Nantucket and there while I'm a
slightly Riley Genghis Khan and they and
we talk about the cancelled Care Act and
it's kind of what you were saying so we
go over the facts oh are you for if you
have a pre-existing condition should you
be covered yes 26 yes all the things so
they agree with I go well that's
Obamacare
oh well I'm still against it because
it's the tribal it's exactly what you're
saying it again becomes a belief
structure and you I don't know how to
change it hey my name is Jeff this
question is directed more at Alison and
Karl it seems to me that when I read
science coverage a lot of it these days
is really focused on the results and the
knowing and it's less interested in the
process of knowing and the process of in
you know of the chain of failures and
surprises that lead to that knowing it's
just the headline result and then I look
at something like political coverage
which seems to me like the exact
opposite we're really focused on these
processes even to personal drama is it
will be filibustered won't they
filibuster and then we kind of forget
that oh we made some policies and what
do these policies actually do and what
are the results there and I think to me
that political coverage and science
coverage could maybe swap places or you
just don't learn from each other so as
my question is and I realized that the
leading question is you think that the
way that we cover science has
contributed to this mistrust in science
or this belief that this thing you know
bombarded this contradictory studied
results and stuff has that contributed
to people's loss of faith in facts
I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure it has right
I mean I think I think that um so when I
was going through journals in school
like you sort of you take people on
these little these little leaps to face
you know it's a balance between how do
you get them to come with you in the
story that they're not going to know and
maybe not going to understand
maybe there's a and they D and B and C
you should have to get them to just
again take the leaps of faith and so
balancing that with what you're saying
about how much you know how much do they
actually want to know I'm not sure I
know the answer to that what do you
think I know well I think I I think it
is a problem I but I think it's a
problem in the kind of science /
medicine writing that people read most
so you know if I'm writing about you
know some old fossils and might or might
not be the oldest fossils on earth I
mean you know if you're writing about
for the New York Times you're going to
get a good readership but if you're
writing an article that is you know
here's here's how we're going to cure
Alzheimer's like bang like this gets a
lot of people are going to be better or
like here's how you can lose 50 pounds
and you know from science or whatever
it's that it's a lot of health stuff
that's really problematic and a lot of
the problem is that from the press
releases on there's a real you know
there's a there's a an urge to get
people to read something to pay
attention by trying to give more
certainty to the results than are really
warranted and you know and then you know
two months later turns out that you know
caffeine which hadn't supposedly had one
kind of effect had the exact opposite
effect
and you know I think that that can that
can sort of leave people kind of
wondering well why are they kind of
running around in a circle I guess I
feel like I have the luxury or maybe
people who write about cosmology and
Johnny we have the luxury of saying like
here here are scientists who are sort of
part of a tradition that goes way back
to Newton or to Darwin and they're just
trying to like be part of that process
and you know the results are provisional
and here's where we could go from there
I mean that's what I get to write about
in my articles but so but but I think
with health coverage in particular
that's that's been an issue are you
saying that journalists have a like
almost a motive to hype results the same
as the scientists do like to sell papers
or well you know I well look I mean
there's going to be there's there's
there's always going to be that I must
put it as a temptation maybe you know
like journalists journalists have to
have principles and have ethics and
those sort of protect us from making
these sorts of mistakes and it's tough I
mean and you know and you can work
really hard to be like super I don't
know how much does it happen to you but
like you're being super duper careful
just like choosing every little word to
make sure you're not going over the line
that you're not misleading people and so
on and then it's time for someone to
stick the headline on and then top like
all your care is undone and because part
of the problem now I think is that
headlines are what travel through social
media so after a while people just see
the headline in the Facebook Creed and
we may or may not get around to read I
definitely wonder what I mean and
YouTube are concerned about this as a
matter of craft and that makes sense
that you would be but the premise that
of the question or maybe the answers to
that how can we make sure science
doesn't suffer as a result of our
reporting science scientists aren't
distrusted that there is no scientists
aren't under siege the the the measure
in the general social survey that for 40
years on how much people have confidence
in various institutions like the press
and organized business and the financial
sector in Congress and the president Oh
in the science community
the science community for 40 years has
been in second place every time and
sometimes the military and sometimes
medicine is ahead but always second
place if you look at Republicans well
it's always been second place if you
look at people who are high and low Jia
City science community always in second
place ahead of or the people who run
organized religion we live in a society
that is astonishingly Pro science and
one of the ways you can tell it is that
on all these debates like climate change
both sides think that science is on
their side right the same way armies
think that God is on their side
it's fighting words to say that you're
your anti science if you mean that
science isn't getting the money it
should you know that that's probably
true but people think that you were
spending too little on science so I
think the premise that science is under
siege is kind of trope people who are
frustrated with issues like climate
change use but it's not rooted in fact
and it also does convey that this kind
of animosity to the other people you're
you're in trying to engage with
hi my name is Chris I'm a graduate
student in the mbmb Department where
professors in Rose appointed and
something that's sort of Concerned me a
little bit in our education here is that
I think the communication aspect on the
conveyance of the science that we
actually do isn't something that
necessarily gets valued in our committee
meetings say and and I think that it
really is to the detriment of the
endeavor on the whole I think that I'm
wondering your thoughts about how we can
inject more valuation of science
communication in our educational system
because I'm always afraid that you know
we're going to reproduce this polluted
environment that Professor Kahana has
been talking about where we get trained
in doing the science and then not
telling anybody about it and then we get
into this identity group of scientists
who nobody else finds with and then they
don't end up believing us and so I think
that that I love to hear a comments
about you know that's sort of dynamic
and maybe a way to disentangle the
identity from the actual facts that we
find that's a really good question you
know I do think Chris Lim right yeah hi
I said that was yeah it's a little hard
to see from your up good communicator
where you complain it you know I do
think ideal for your Christmas mind just
sneer at science communication sometimes
if you look at Carl Sagan was one of the
great explicate errs of the unit how the
universe works
you know people kind of snipe at him oh
yeah but he's not really you know
scientist all Willy wrote four hundred
papers well he you know he didn't really
but I knew his professional jealousy for
most part and I also think that it's an
age thing that I think that you know
younger generation sees communicating
science as part and parcel of what they
do as you do and I think that the older
folks just have to get out of the way
and and could could you to find older
well unfortunately I'm in that bin so
you know it was very simple ten years
older than I am I think I think people
my vintage we there was just never a
value you it was anything that had
anything that took you out of the lab
communicating science
your family you know having a life
anything that took you out of the lab
was was negative now obviously that's
evolving because we think people ought
to be full human beings but I think
that's what I mean by aging people in my
vintage just did not do anything beyond
research well what about our education
on scientists this came up in discussion
we those of us who do science to me is
like being a professional baseball
player if you ever watch me play
baseball
pathetic I can play but I love watching
it I love understanding it I can play it
and I wonder which science not
everyone's going to be a scientist and
then play these be the athlete to do
science it's like being a professional
athlete constantly being judged it's
hard but do we do a good enough job
teaching the future politicians the
future leaders of America
what we really do I'm afraid we don't
maybe that may relate to your question
of Education maybe we should have more
sort of more discourse where the
scientists are teaching the non
scientists about what we're doing
scientific method getting the points
that both of us made about what we
really do is a narrative like there
seems to be this narrative that around
STEM education in particular where you
know you if you have a stem if you study
stem you're going to get a good job
there's value there all the difference
or brackets pay and what up means do we
any more scientist in that regard and
like is that the right narrative to be
to take to be giving people you know
like is that so yeah that you're going
to Canadian scientist I mean it's very
very important all fraction of of the
nation has good science literacy very
small fraction and a lot of what we
confront needs scientific expertise so
there's no question in my mind we could
benefit from having more scientists but
happens like that but the hook is sort
of like you should study science because
you're going to get a high paying job
but sometimes the narrative around it
right that you hear I said that yeah I
think that actually the engineering has
more of that and doing them but yes they
both do
you know people should do what they love
and then they'll be good at it but what
troubles me is ya steering people into
careers because they'll make more money
just doesn't seem very yet I think is
there also just an inherent value and
knowing it I go there when we're talking
tonight about how having this literacy
about having this curiosity about it and
so like is there a way to steer people
toward it for other for those reasons so
so I have two daughters one of whom it
majored in English writing at Yale and
one time we were talking and I said you
know honey I said in physics we're
trying to teach people how to st. and
she goes mom what do you think they're
doing an English department again Oprah
high-priced career you know how to think
I mean really yeah all those every piece
of the academic world has its role and
we ought to be thinking about like where
where is the student matched to the
thing they are passionate about because
that's where productivity is but do we
put a veil around a scientist we put a
veil around it so we do say that so
people don't sit some number so once
distinct on the airplane
a master physicists well you okay I mean
yeah if it's something that we do and
not and then so non scientists say well
I can never understand it so why bother
and I think we can explain almost
everything maybe a few things from
quantum mechanics and still tough but by
and large nothing in biology is that
complicate I think the reason they think
they can't understand is because they
didn't have very good science teaching
ever certainly in elementary school high
school yeah yeah at one point like this
I mean I think that'd be the impediments
that any graduate program place in the
way of a scientist in training who wants
to be able to share the knowledge with
the public is making a mistake because
that's just an intrinsic good in our
society it might help a little but it
won't hope help enough to resolve the
the big science communication problems
that we have we need
science of science communication and we
need to have people who are being
trained to be professionals in that
maybe there'll be professionals and
saying things but mainly they're going
to be professionals in ways of
understanding what all those
intermediary institutions are like and
how they can get their wires crossed and
so you have to have a kind of
convergence between the natural science
faculties and the social science
faculties for social science departments
have to be on board with students who
want to apply themselves in that way and
I think when I go to different schools I
see lots of different models of that and
we're doing things like that here
at Yale called Carl's Henry's teaching
things all the time and and they're
initiatives to try to tie together the
communication focused departments in the
school with the Natural Science one but
it's not obvious what to do
so what's obvious is that everybody
should be trying something and then in a
systematic way evaluating how that how
that's working well I I think it's
important to to give a say grad students
some some good so to recognize that it's
not that that they are incredibly busy
with all these different things and you
know learning how this machine works and
figuring out how to do statistics and so
on and and to then expect them to sort
of naturally be able to just start
talking with Carl Sagan's eloquence or
Neil Tyson's eloquence like it just just
doesn't happen and I know that for a
fact I mean so if I will say ask a
science grad student to sit down and you
know just explain this paper to me and
say 600 words or have them stand up and
I just say look just tell me what you do
it's like the language just switches on
to science speak and it's and it's they
feel they're you know they've been
taught to feel very comfortable with
with the language of their tribe and
legs sort of haven't forgotten how to
talk even though like they would never
say you
words coming out their mouths they would
never say to like their friends but it's
just served like this is how I speak of
science in jargon so it takes effort and
time time that graduate students I think
should be afforded to get better at that
my opinion in the back okay
hi my name is Chad I'm a graduate
student in chemistry I'm so I feel like
oftentimes we create this
us-against-them when it when it comes to
science and I wonder if the word science
itself is misunderstood by the general
population and I wonder if we pointed
out to kind of those around us when they
do science outside of labs just in their
everyday life if that would help mediate
that problem and so I just wondered if
you guys could comment on that and what
your thoughts are well I don't know
about the word scientist but I know that
and was made to think of this as you
were speaking you think of how but how
popular show MythBusters was what was
that about like the two guys are sitting
there in the couch like normal guys and
one of them says I have a question and
as what well if we drop the penny off
the Empire State Building would it
really go through somebody's skull and
the guys well let's go - oh we can't
yeah and this is like the scientific
moment that the thing that's
unobservable that you want to explain
well what can we observe from which we
can draw inferences about this thing the
whole rest of the show is about the
scientific method and they say
jury-rigged some kind of a shotgun and
of course one of them shoots the other
at the end of the at the end of the show
but people love that they love the idea
that somebody had a question and then
came up with a strategy to try to solve
it that was experimental in this way I
mean that that was such a popular show
really says something about our society
and where they scientist one of them was
asked by a little girl I guess was in
third grade who loved them I want to be
a scientist just like you
well the main difference Tyson
scientists is we don't have to write
everything down but if you've got a
group of people who are watching people
do experiments and use Sciences way of
knowing and find that entertaining well
you've got a pretty good base to work
off of to get rid of the problems we
have that block people from getting the
benefit of the best science we have
people will take whatever tools they
have to understand the universe I think
everyone wants to understand the
fundamental questions of why we're here
why we're on earth had of things work
what the universe is about and the move
in and so you develop a structure to try
to understand it the difference is that
we try to use evidence as he said
earlier we observe and we don't start
with a belief structure we start with
evidence and because it very beautifully
said whereas often other methodology
start with a belief structure ie
vaccination or and I think trying to
teach scientific method of what we do is
start with honest observation make
models it's just what we do well and
also science has not been limited to
what goes on in a lab say for a long
time I mean bird watchers have
contributed huge amounts of valuable
information that have gone into research
on bird populations and and how they
respond to climate and so on has been
going on for like almost a century with
with autobahns programs and with
computers now and the internet i mean
this is like a good thing about the
internet i think is that it's actually
like it is totally accelerated the
citizen science movement so you know you
know people actually want to sit down
and stare at galaxies and classify them
for free they like that they like being
a part of the scientific process you
know people will fold proteins for you
together and let me work on that for
like an hour or or will math know
this stuff is happening and you know
there was a paper a couple years ago for
about protein folding it was published
in nature it's 50,000 authors because
they're just folks who just were folding
it on their computer through a program
called folded so you know people want to
do science people die agree damn and
people do like science and it's so you
do want to be careful that you know a
word science doesn't just scare them off
and so maybe programs like this can can
help hi I think we need help from
science writers or the intermediary
group as it was defined tonight to
explain that science is not a fact
science is not a fact it's a method is a
process I would say to die and we
scientist delight in contradictory
results and we learn from difference it
is not consume it out it is that's the
essence of it and then we develop newer
theories to account for those difference
and then we go ahead and prove those new
theories so that's the process right so
we make laws that are newer to account
for new evidence that cumulates all the
time in these evidence White's new
because it's contradicting the old one
so this is the thing and the public
doesn't understand that also because
it's our fault when we write a paper
we're all getting excited about this new
thing that was for the first time
showing unfortunately the publishing
industry doesn't head because we can't
publish contradictory results you can
publish negative results that's a very
big issue so we need some change we need
help and we need change from all sides
because we do it but we don't know how
to explain it well and the public gets
it wrong it's not a fact it's absolutely
not a fact and you will change one day
so we like that but the public you know
if it's accepted as a belief obviously
will want I think this gets back to the
point that we've been discussing earlier
that we make models and new data comes
along and refines the model changes it
the models are good as they can predict
and models can be it approaches truth as
we said Newtonian physics in the
universe we live in
it's probably it's better good at truth
as we're ever going to get but
nevertheless still a model and I think
we all understand that but communicating
it to the public I think is important I
agree I have to say this at this point
that you know it really points up a big
divide between practicing scientists and
and everybody else that we we get really
excited when we find out we're wrong yes
and most of the world is going to what
that's a bad thing and we get excited
when as you say you know we find that a
theory is wrong there's new evidence
whatever and that's a confusion for
everyone else they just don't follow
that that's something that we could
maybe try harder to to take on
explicitly well yeah I sometimes when
I'm interviewing scientists and they're
like obsessing over like oh here's the
thing that we have no clue about it's
wide open and I feel like oh so you
don't know anything and then like oh no
no of course you know like you mean of
course like you know there there is you
know you're not saying that oh that
Einstein what did he know they are
saying it right director see we don't
know a thing okay okay right but you're
not real
exciting totally at random right yeah so
so you need to remember that you know
you're looking at it the all the things
you don't know yet and you're standing
on all the stuff that you're actually
taking for granted at this oh you're
bored by that yeah that's gorgeous the
rest of us that might be new to us yeah
yeah in fact for years I used to give
this talk we're about ten minutes into
the talk I would give it a slide that
shows the scale of the universe and sort
of multiplicative you know powers of a
million or whatever and this was purely
pedagogical right just just I want you
to understand the size of the universe
so I can explain the really interesting
stuff that slide got more attention than
anything else it took me a long time to
figure out it's exactly what you're
saying to me that was just you know
routine but
was yeah anyway there's a wonderful
paper danger your audience so private of
twenty years ago talking about
scientific discovery using the model the
number of rivers on earth and if you
were in the 14th century and you were
mapping the number of rivers it seemed
to be an insurmountable problem but
problems in kids become answer at one
level and now we've mapped probably
every river on earth and so things get
solved and we don't even acknowledge
that they at one level been solved and
we move on as as you just said and we
stand on top of it and move to the next
science is always about what we don't
know yeah that's a great percent Kyle's
going to come back up I think the second
anyway there we go yeah
Carl Zimmer meguri Dan kahan David
Hassler and Alison Schneider please give
them a round of applause
[Applause]
[Music]